nobody has bothered us until last year
that 29 of June that was that beginning
to my night nightmare I'm getting scared
I'm really getting scared you know I
really make it on what I have now this
desolate patch of desert on the
outskirts of Los Angeles County is known
as the Antelope Valley few people want
to live here and the collection of
rugged individualists hsihu do are being
chased away by what the county officials
call nuisance abatement teams armed
County inspection squads that target
zoning and code violations the plight of
these desert dwellers made regional
headlines when Kim Fay he's home known
as phone henge was raided by a nuisance
abatement team a colorful castle built
by Fahey himself out of old telephone
poles phone henge was a gift to the
media which covered the county's
prosecution of Fahey as an offbeat human
interest story but Fahey was convicted
of 12 misdemeanors he's been jailed and
forced to destroy his own home so have
many other Valley property owners
targeted by the county's code
enforcement forces and many of these
folks have even fewer resources than
Fahey this guy had this property for
sale for a good price so I came out here
and looked at it and say wow this is
pretty cool Joey Gallo is a retired Army
veteran who served during the Vietnam
era
last year the candy began performing
unannounced inspections on his property
government came out and he told me that
my bushes and stuff out here had to be
cut back is okay no problem Gallo says
he cooperated with the county clearing
brush then moving a shed then getting
rid of his motor home finally the county
made a demand that shocked him they told
me you know we have to get off the
property I said you know I get off the
property he says well yeah you can't
live here Gallo says County officials
told him that neighbors whom they would
not identify had complained about
unsightly structures on his property
he could keep his land they told him but
would not be allowed to live on it I
looked at dummy nice as well for what
mine close neighbors like a half mile
away we're not living in Beverly Hills
here this is my home our side we got
police at my front door
bulletproof bass guns then he surrounded
place everything I worked for
you know was like like just melting away
from me I don't know where I'm gonna go
I really don't miles from gallo and a
remote corner of the Antelope Valley
Oscar Castaneda has also been ordered to
destroy his own property Castaneda is a
mechanic and a seventh-day Adventist
preacher and he also happens to own the
church where the movies Kill Bill 1 and
2 were shot like many of the residents
here
Castaneda and his wife grow their own
food supply their own power with solar
panels and their own water from a well
their green energy lifestyle is a choice
not subsidized by the government as a
member of the seventh-day Adventist
Church we believe in living independent
of the city living by yourself
Castaneda lived in the desert for 22
years without any help from or problems
with the government that changed last
year the city and some other cars drew
right into my property
they said that they were here to help me
and I don't know in which way they are
helping me the government officials who
had entered without a warrant left after
taking pictures says Castaneda but this
was the first of many visits if you
don't know the rights you don't have him
so when they came the first time the
second time the third time in the fourth
time I didn't know that I had to ask
them for a warrant
members of the nuisance abatement team
began pointing out compliance problems
too many vehicles on the property
improper water tank and so on all of
these the county said to him are a
nuisance and a danger to his neighbor's
right here going as looking north there
no neighbor there one in two abandoned
house I don't have no neighbors over
here let's say ten miles in no neighbors
over here another ten miles so I'm
leaving in the middle of nowhere okay
and I'm not bothering anyone the county
ordered Castaneda to get a building
permit to keep his home on the property
but will not issue a permit unless he
connects to the county's power grid and
drills a new water well between $75,000
and $100,000 to bring the electricity to
my lot the only way I have is move out
of here as a matter of fact I already
started doing that
Castaneda and Gallo are only two of many
such targets of Los Angeles County's
nuisance abatement teams which were
commissioned in 2006 by County
Supervisor Mike Antonovich
but the county's heavy-handed tactics
are beginning to spur resistance the
story of the GNAT raids was told by LA
Weekly reporter Mars melnikov recently
they're picking on people who are the
most defenseless and have the least
resources and also a lot of time almost
like unknowledgeable about their rights
a group called the Antelope Valley
Truckers organization is fighting back
against the county you people are the
majority is we the people
stand up for your [ __ ] at this meeting
several attendees had horror stories
about encounters with the county they
have black jackets on sidearms taser
guns m16s paintball guns I lost two
thousand five hundred dollars of income
because they they said that my mobile
homes were illegal this is intimidation
this is domestic terrorists this is
trespassing they said that we had to get
rid of everything we have they pointed
to the dirt and said see that ground
right there we want your whole place to
look like that but why is the county
intent on driving these loners who rely
on themselves and seemingly affect
nobody out of this desert there are many
theories from those being pushed out I
think it's a future development putting
a highway through here I think you know
when Airport conjures at land properties
can be worth something there's a high
desert corner which it goes from the 14
to the 15 if they can give people off
their property and buy that land to
somebody can make a lot of fun I believe
is more control if they have you living
in one place they can control you better
clearing way for an airport or a highway
making plans for housing developments
maybe high-speed rail this video from
the county's Department of Regional
Planning contains lengthy descriptions
of process but no insight about the
government's goal for land is cleared of
residents gathering community members at
four different locations across the
valley we first created a common vision
for the future but to get some real
answers we had to ask the county
officials themselves unfortunately our
interview requests were turned down by
County Supervisor Mike Antonovich deputy
district attorney David Campbell the Los
Angeles County Planning Department the
LA County Department of Public Works and
the Antelope Valley Department of
Regional Planning so we decided to
attend a County Board of Supervisors
meeting to ask Mike Antonovich why these
individuals are being forced from their
homes we had made a few requests to talk
with mr. Antonovich to no avail so
that's why I'm here just ask a few
questions and hopefully get a few
answers we want to know how using
nuisance abatement teams to force
Antelope Valley residents to destroy
their houses and vacate their properties
is in the public interest and that's
directed at mr. Antonovich perhaps I can
clarify that the time for public comment
doesn't require responses we were
informed that Antonovich was not
required to respond in this public venue
and at the conclusion of the time
Antonovich simply requested written
record of the questions and said he
would get back to us afterwards we were
approached by Antonovich as press
secretary Tony Bell who refused to
comment on camera but said that the
county is simply responding to code
violation complaints from neighbors in
the area and any speculation about
redevelopment is purely a conspiracy
theory
meanwhile for a purpose that nobody
knows the county continues driving away
the few people who still want to live
there anything not covered in the area
plan is covered by the countywide
general plan if the general plan is like
a house with all the basic rooms an area
plan is like in addition to a house it
adds additional value for some residents
but could not stand alone from the main
house people showed us where the key
centers of activity were what areas were
right for what kinds of development and
what places should be preserved the
public can still provide input at every
step of the way
so please stay tuned
[Music]
you
[Music]